hey youtubers is Charlie this week on
Korra things totally got real so there
are two more episodes they haven't
really said whether or not they're gonna
post that at the same time or if it just
gonna be one episode per week for the
next two weeks I'll be sure to update
with more information but Janet Varney
and some of the cast we're talking about
how this season's finale is going to be
different from books 1 & 2 so after we
get through top 5 WTF moments and my
review I'll explain what they said if
you're finding me for the first time I
do core videos every week I even do a
weekly giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video and a lot of you
are asking - and as soon as Korra goes
off the air I will do more bonus videos
but then Friday's is pluggin Abbey when
Star Wars rebels is going to air in
October so that's just gonna be my new
Friday animated show that I'll do videos
for careful for spoilers from episode 11
if you haven't seen it yet but here are
my top 5 WTF moments I'll wait just a
second okay ready here we go number 5
chaos embossing say I didn't expect to
hear to actually kill the earth Queen
but it looks like that's what happened
which is also bad news for the ending in
this episode but the city is a complete
shitstorm right now and everyone is
looting everything this totally reminds
me of big times in history went great
empires felt like the fall of Rome the
vandals the big Germanic tribes sacked
Rome and made off with some of their
greatest treasures just like people are
making off with the earth Queens
greatest treasures that's where the term
vandalism comes from it was during the
decline and fall of the Roman Empire
after the government collapsed Europe
entered the Dark Ages that's just the
period in real world history between the
fall of the Roman Empire in the
beginning of the Renaissance the big
question to ask is is this the path that
the world of Korra is on there was no
Zaheer in real life no one person that
just crushed Rome it was a long gradual
process the answer to all that though
was the beginning of the Renaissance the
word Renaissance means rebirth it was a
period that started after the creation
of movable type and you know easy
fabrication of paper it became this big
cultural movement all over Europe that
led to a new age of creative thinking
art culture and society so rewind to
where we are in core right now we're at
the fall of Ba Sing se implying that the
world might be entering the void so to
speak entering its own Dark Age a period
of chaos that Zaheer's trying to create
so that society will rebirth
self in ushering in a new renaissance of
spiritual enlightenment that's why I
love the character so much that's why I
love Z here just because he is so crazy
but his logic is solid it's what would
totally happen people would find a way
to thrive no matter what the hundred
year war led to the rise of Aang and a
new age of peace that was like a minor
version of what Zaheer is trying to do
he's trying to burn the field so that
new crops can go stronger than before we
don't know anything about book 4 right
now so we have no idea how far his plan
is going to progress there were a few
surprises during the mock alone Bolin
escaped from the city mostly grandma she
is glued to that picture of the earth
Queen I hope they explained whether it's
because she's stuck in her ways or if
she has some sort of special connection
with the Queen it's possible that they
included that saint just so that they
could get that funny moment with Bolin
throwing her over his shoulder like a
sack of potatoes moving on to number 4
su Yin in the metal clan a couple of big
red flags here first if you have seen
any of my previous core videos you know
I totally do not trust su Yin and
there's the possibility that this clown
person in her circus group was too here
that's not confirmed or anything but the
minute su Yin said let's bring an army
of highly trained metal benders all
loyal to me I felt like team Korra was
headed for disaster su Yin totally feels
like the kind of person that would drink
Sahir's kool-aid someone who's really
into the idea of a renaissance it's
possible that she's totally genuine I
don't think she's gonna be solid good or
solid evil she seems like a Zaheer
apologist
but you can let me know if you agree if
I were a linter core though I don't know
that I'd feel comfortable taking an army
of metal benders into battle that I
didn't know were absolutely loyal to me
I did really like soohyun's armor though
that was really cool before the metal
bending artistry that we saw this season
Lin putting on our armor in the morning
was one of my favorite metal bending
sequences just her getting her eye on
man swerve on speaking of which I know a
lot of you feel like bolin might learn
to lava ben instead of learning to
metalbend it seems like if you can
master one difficult form of subheading
you could totally master the other
they're both earth forms usually it's a
psycho-spiritual thing I know major
forms of bending are tied to lineage but
sub bending isn't some midi-chlorian
[ __ ] genetics thing I would be so
upset if that were the case I don't
think that Mike and Bryan would troll
the fandom doing something like that
though on to number three
Korra meets Iroh again
this was a nice surprise a bit strange
with the timing but very welcome
especially that they paid the moment off
with Zuko later I'm surprised that he
would be surprised IRA was in the spirit
realm you think that Zuko would have
reached the level of spirituality that
would allow him to commune with IRA but
I guess that's not the case really what
was going on is that Korra was trying to
call us to here out using his own
methods against him but instead she ran
into Iroh in case you missed it though
there was a big Last Airbender reference
the advice that Iroh gave to Korra about
finding things you weren't looking for
was the same advice that he gave to
young Zuko whenever they were hiding out
in Ba Sing se I always love it when Mike
and Bryan bring Last Airbender moments
into the new series the whole meeting
with Iroh is a little out of place but
think of it is like a vastly shorter
version of the Iroh episode from book to
Korra needs a lesson from Yoda before
she flies to the Death Star to face
Darth Vader in the Emperor and when she
did talk to Zuko I feel like he was
telling her Aang would have died to
protect the airbenders he backtracked a
little saying that Aang had a greater
responsibility to the world but an
alternative take on the scene is that he
was implying Aang would have killed team
Zaheer if faced with the choice even
though killing is one of the greatest
taboos of the air nation you could also
use that logic to say that Sahir is not
a true airbender if he's killing people
thus the [ __ ] starts to hit the fan
number 2 team Zaheer versus the air
nation the animation and fight
choreography on the whole air temple
part of the episode was so above and
beyond anything I'd ever seen on the
series before I loved the animation on
Avatar Juan's episodes just because they
were so unique but inside the normal
core episodes this is the new king of
fight scenes I know I made some Star
Wars references to Iroh and Korra
earlier but it only makes sense that my
mind would jump to obi-wan Kenobi when I
think about Tenzin it's like his scene
with Sahir his fight scene was obi-wan
Kenobi fighting Darth Vader in episode 4
they gave him that same type of pan away
ending that they gave to the earth Queen
so if she's dead it seems like they want
us to think that Tenzin is dead too I'll
follow up on that in a sec but I was
also really happy to see that they let
Kai take on minghua the combustion
bender I totally did not expect the
downer ending so I actually thought that
he was gonna take that airship down
whenever he took her on just like Lin
took down the airship during book 1 it's
a children's show so I totally
understand why they showed us him
surviving with the Bey
be air bison rescue I think if they cut
that scene then the episode would have
had a lot more dramatic weight but I
understand that if they had made kids
think that KY had died Nick probably
would have gotten a million angry
letters from the parents of crying
children I know a lot of the Phantom
isn't a huge fan of KY so be honest and
you know no judging here would you be
okay with Mike and Brian killing him
like letting him officially die in the
fall I would have been okay with it but
again killing children is not something
you see on Korra at least I can't
remember them ever killing a child at
least in an explicit way Jett from last
airbender is one of the few exceptions
but technically he was not a little a
kid he was older than everyone else on
Team avatar and the killing continues on
to my number one WTF moment team Zaheer
kills Tenzin can we all agree that the
show at least wants us to think that
they killed him I'm sure all will be
revealed in episode 12 but until then
given the way things went down with the
earth Queen Tenzin has left this mortal
coil Enter the Void totally feels like a
metaphor for death now since that's the
title of episode 12 but it's not the
finale I'm really curious if Korra is
going to have a major out-of-body
adventure in book 4 at this point the
best theory I've seen so far is that
sohere watts Korra to refuse raava and
vaatu which creates a whole mess of
logic issues based on what happened
during book 2 but if she hears already
accomplished his goal of revolution what
more could he need core for that he
could not do himself he does need the
portals to be open which they already
are so I don't think that has anything
to do with the connection of the spirit
realm in the physical realm he could be
trying to reset things to pre avatar
want status me he has to kill Korra
while she's in the Avatar state that
would end the cycle of the avatar if
that happened I suppose raava's
connection would be severed and I don't
think that raava would cease to exist
let me know what you think that Zaheer's
plan for korra is but here is the logic
issue that I was talking about between
raava and vaatu during the book 2 finale
raava was wiped out reset to her zero
state under normal conditions
she would have reemerged from vaatu in
10,000 years no matter what story the
show presented in the finale you can
never kill evil or good absolutely
they'll always exist their fundamental
states of existence it's just using the
terms evil and good are our subjective
ways of describing them you can call
raava and vaatu something else but
neither one will ever be
completely destroyed they just get
suppressed for a period of 10,000 years
so in the finale last year Jinora
just forcibly sped up raava's
reemergence so you can't influence their
cycle you cannot stop it more to the
book 2 finale I take issue with the fact
that avatar once separated raava and
vaatu if that were true then there would
have been no part of raava inside vaatu
for Jinora to extract that implies that
they were never truly separated it's a
big problem that I'm trying not to
overthink but let me know what your
opinion is on the issue of Robin Basu
and if it has anything to do with the
book 3 finale overall I just gave this
episode a solid a plus for killing a
beloved character or not being afraid to
kill a beloved character and doing it
with the best possible animation
eight-plus is all around the linen
soo-eun scenes in the airship dragged
just a little IRA felt a little out of
place overall but everything was totally
amazing one of the things I did notice
is that they seem to rush a lot of the
Korra portions of the episode like the
real action of the episode was up at the
air temple and they just rushed through
the core parts so that they could get to
that the Iroh Last Airbender moment was
totally adorable even if it made Zuko
feel like a bit of a space cadet the way
he was presented in the Korra universe
as I understood was that he was the new
Iroh like he had achieved a certain
level of enlightenment in the years
since the formation of Republic City and
retiring as the Fire Lord I think they
just wanted a funny callback so for all
intents and purposes Zuko is obi-wan
Kenobi just like Tenzin is and Zuko
calling out his daughter so clearly in
the episode makes me feel like we're
definitely going to see her during book
4 they wouldn't go for seasons teasing a
character and not sure I do wonder why
we haven't seen her yet it feels like
seeing who she is you know physically
Singer rule revealed the long-standing
mystery of Zuko's wife like who did he
marry the best theories I've seen so far
are my but I'm not current on the comics
and I know the comics did reveal some
possibilities about beifong's husband or
one of her husband's so just to address
the book 3 finale Janet Varney some of
the cast were talking a little bit about
how it was different they just said that
it wouldn't be a big spiritual battle
like seasons past meaning Korra will not
have a giant fight with team Zaheer
she's probably going to sacrifice
herself and literally enter the void of
death it just seems like everyone
important is dying this season there is
a core book for it that will be aired on
the website just like the episodes
right now Janet Varney is the star of
that so even if Cora enters the void of
death she is not going to die completely
like she's not going away that brings up
more questions than it answers but I'm
gonna wait till after episode 12 to
start speculating further on book 4 in
the meantime though congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Li Cheng you
win the Amazon gift card I'll be
messaging you on your channel for
details so be sure to check your inbox
while we all try to get over Tenzin
click here to learn about the Star Wars
Episode 7 villains and click here for
last week's core video thanks so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]